I know you just got back from Fashion
Week so tell me what you saw what we all
need to buy what's the new thing I
actually walked in the blonde show and
the clothes are just so out of this
world and so sexy and just the perfect
things to wear when you're doing a
concert and Alison Olivia I love her
collection this year was so beautiful
and I had my big birthday party so it
was a lot of fun just to be with all my
friends in New York celebrating tell me
on a level we know there was another big
celebrity birthday party Jennifer
Aniston just had her party how do you
party on a level like one two Aniston I
feel like you might be at 12 I have
birthdays all around the world I've
already done four and I haven't done the
LA one yet so I come all out I love
birthdays there are rumors clear them up
about Machine Gun Kelly friends maybe a
musical collaboration people say you
might be together oh we're friends I
think he's a very cool guy like this
thing has a cool attitude I like hanging
out with them and British friends chance
you guys could collaborate on music
talent he's very talented let's talk
about tonight why is it important for
you to bring your star power out and
support such a big evening I lost my
grandmother to breast cancer so it's
something that's a really important
cause my heart that we really need to
help find a cure and it's so important
for everyone to be here tonight for this
beautiful evening to support this cause
thank you so much for stopping